it's a fairly gray and dreary morning up
here Ashley laying flat phone I even got
the Under 16's in the background having
a cup match and sadly it's a fairly gray
day for English rugby isn't it because
there was such a great plan put in place
by Stuart Lancaster four years ago
bringing in new players building those
players over the course of four years in
preparation for this tournament this
2015 Rugby World Cup and and sadly you
know it wasn't the Australia game that
there cost us it was the Welsh game you
know and the decisions that happen 20
minutes from the end in that that
stopped us progressing through this
World Cups such a disappointment such a
shame because the lads have worked so
hard I know as a player having been out
there how despondent they'll be this
morning it would just be an awful
morning for them well what do you think
I mean you know it it seems hard to ask
it but you know this is this is sport
and it's a harsh world as you well know
you know should the coach stay on should
Stuart Lancaster stay you know should
should the captain remain well I
absolutely believe that mr. Lancaster
should stay if you look back
historically at teams that have done
well in World Cups Clive Woodward
obviously in 2003 back in 99 he had the
disappointment of losing to South Africa
in the quarter-final a home World Cup
for us then as well Graham Henry 2007
New Zealand unthinkably losing to France
in that quarter-final then going on and
winning in 2011 so for me the maybe the
mistake was made that Martin Johnson was
was let to disappear from the English
game if he'd retained his position off
2011 Austria Langosta probably would be
in that set up still with him building
what he's built culturally and heritage
Lee behind the scenes with England at
the moment and I feel we'd be in a
stronger position had they done so so
now I feel the RFU have evolved as a set
up since then for years they're pulling
together they understand they've really
evolved as an entity and I believe
they'll keep Stuart Lancaster for the
next four years but they'll without
doubt there'll be a big and a strong
review over what's happened and why it
happened and and who's to blame and
without their finger-pointing you know
here and now there has to be some
changes made and Louis one of those key
issues about decisions taken and I'm not
talking about they're going to be
analysed forever more I think decisions
taken on the pitch particularly in the
Welsh game but this
decision taken long before the World Cup
took place and it shows the difference I
suppose between the Australian and the
English approach and I'm talking about
players playing overseas England Stuart
Lancaster was resolute those brilliant
players English players playing in
France you would not be eligible the
Australians changed the rules pretty
late and look at the benefits they got
yeah I do it was ridiculous for me that
Matt Guiteau has been away from the
Australian game for four years anyway
when you see what a talent he is when he
played in the World Cup yesterday the
game that he played you know not only
that you have Mitchell coming back in
just some class performers in Pocock and
Hooper around the breakdown that's
stifled our game to be quite honest
England played some good rugby they got
into Australia's 22 but we're constantly
stifled by those two hour and out sevens
and you talk about overseas players the
one in particular that people are
talking about this morning is Stefan
Armitage now he is an out-and-out seven
something that England haven't naturally
produced over the years you know and
out-and-out seven that goes and gets the
ball the last week and probably the
first we ever had was Neil back you know
you go back to Winterbottom Gary Rees
they weren't really out announce Richard
Hill wasn't so we need to invest if we
want out and out 7s in this game we need
to invest more time into producing them
because the way that the breakdown the
refereeing is done over here doesn't
really allow for it do I think that's
true at Lancaster and England going
forward should be allowed to pick
overseas players very much so I you
can't have a European Player of the Year
twice not included in your international
setup but having said that if Stuart
Lancaster makes a decision that he's not
going to pick them and we're not gonna
pick overseas players he's not then
going to go back on it just for one
individual but it is a shame I think
that we didn't see Stefan whether he
would have made the starting lineup or
not involved in that squad